[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to
the quickstart tutorial
for BigQuery, Google Cloud's
large-scale data warehouse
for storage and analysis.
In this video,
we're going to walk
through how to analyze data
stored in BigQuery using the BQ
command-line tool.
To start, visit
console.cloud.google.com
to open the Google
Cloud console.
This web portal allows
you to manage and explore
your Cloud resources
directly from a browser.
Create a new project by clicking
the Project Viewer button
at the top of your screen.
Once it's ready, you'll get
a notification saying so.
Click the Notifications
icon, and then
click Select Project to
open your new project.
Next, activate Cloud
Shell by clicking its icon
to the right of the search bar.
Cloud Shell is an online
development environment
that comes preloaded
with helpful tools
for interacting with
your Cloud resources.
Once it launches, click
the Maximize button
to increase the size of
the Cloud Shell terminal.
Now you'll use the
BQ command-line tool
to explore one of
the sample tables
provided in BigQuery, the
Shakespeare table, which
contains an entry for every
word in every Shakespeare play.
You can use the bq show
command to display information
about the table.
Type bq show plus the table
reference and the command
prompt.
If prompted, make sure to
click Authorize to authorize
Cloud Shell to make API calls.
You will then see information
about the table returned,
including a schema and size.
You can learn more about how
to use the BQ command-line tool
by typing in bq help.
You can also view information
about a specific command.
Here, we can ask for information
about the bq query command.
Now let's run an SQL query
over the Shakespeare table
using the bq query command.
This query, which is
available following
the link in the
description below,
calculates how many times
the substring raisin
appears in Shakespeare's works.
The output shows that
while raisins appears once,
the raisin substring
also appears in words
like praising and raising.
We can also query to see
how many times the substring
huzzah appears.
Since the substring does not
appear in Shakespeare's works,
no results are returned.
Now let's create a new table
and place it in a new data set.
Our sample data will come
from the US Social Security
Administration, and contains
about seven megabytes of data
about popular baby names.
First, visit the link
in the description
below and download
the baby names
zip file to your local device.
Open the file YOB2010.txt
to see what it looks like.
It contains comma-separated
values for three columns--
name, sex, and number of
children with that name.
Next, upload the YOB2010.txt
file from your local device
to Cloud Shell.
Using the three-dotted
More menu,
you can confirm that the
file was successfully
uploaded to the Cloud Shell
environment by running ls.
Run bq ls to check whether your
project has existing data sets.
Now we can run the bq mk command
to create a new data set called
baby names for our own project.
If we run bq ls again, we
can see that our new data set
appears as part of our project.
In the baby names data set that
you created, use the bq load
command to load
your source file,
YOB2010.txt, into a new
table called Names 2010.
This command creates a table
and loads data in a single step.
You can provide the data set ID,
table ID, source, and schema.
Once the upload is complete,
confirm that the table now
appears in the data set by
running bq ls babynames.
You can also view
the table schema
by running bq show,
babynames.names2010.
Now that the table
is loaded, we can
run some queries on the data,
again using the bq query
command.
For example, this query returns
the most popular girls' names.
And this one returns
some unusual boys' names.
Now that you've successfully
run your queries,
make sure to complete a
few quick cleanup steps.
To avoid incurring storage
charges to your Google Cloud
account for the resources
used in this quickstart,
run this bq rm command and
confirm the Delete command
by typing in y.
To finish cleanup,
type rm YOB2010.txt
to remove the file that you
uploaded to your Cloud Shell
environment.
And that's it.
You're now equipped to
run queries and load data
using the BQ command-line tool.
Make sure to check out the rest
of our BigQuery documentation
at
cloud.google.com/BigQuery/Docs
to learn more about how to use
BigQuery to gain insights about
your data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]